захаль но середнього світу можна з
дубутими Льоші в школі а із закладах
профосфіти про секцію протюя школі Арі
Вступай до профтеху після 9 класу та за
три роки проходить програму повну
зохальне середнє свити А за складним і
професіям до 3,5 уроки паралельного з
новою ж рубають менше професію так
можна після нас забуті дві оновити
три інтегровані не професії я хто
кухаркундитор обкриває закрини в
кентина вшані студенти складають
кваліфікацію
про загальну середнього світу так і диплом
про професій
студенти проходить у молодшого Ну практику
те, що ти зможеш зарубатися
[музика]
приклади руку до реалізації таланту
Іди до профтеху
[музика]